[Musique]
et alors et alors moi non plus j'ai pas
d'âge et je fais pas chier le monde
depuis quelques temps vous pouvez vous
laisser aller à tous vos fantasmes avec
le téléphone rose
osez le sexe par téléphone 200 francs la
minute à nos sos désir arrive mon biquet
elle faisait désirer tuheiava la plus
coquine à plus sensuelle de toutes les
réponses 2 veut dire que tu es bien
tomber toi il va le battre à plaisir
quel est ton type de femme
grande blonde est plutôt charles veut
que vous correspondez à me faut un
méchant case où on this correspond un
téton tu as tu peux pas savoir
amat 72 96 60 96 les cheveux couleur
saïda ont beau charmant rires tu vois
quoi une belle bouche bien sûr j'ai une
belle bouche sur gmail gauche c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire tout de
suite
on sait pas ce que j'aimerais faire
bosser mais vous non non pas de loi pas
tu vois pas en train de manger ton petit
corps vouthon picard
on le sent bien que ça chouette à une
petite école
vraiment dis moi mon biquet beau stade
de la conversation là on en a mis sept
enfants et vous poursuivre on harel
comme tu veux je préfère vous appelez le
mois prochain mais sa tendresse oui
d'accord c'est un peu cher mais alors
qu'ils avertissent ces projets du tout
comme son mari plus baup le mien ben
c'est normal
j'utilise le savant du cas pour le
sahara en garde les parents qui vous
savez depuis peu à fr3 est devenue la
chaîne de la culture aussi nous avons le
plaisir de vous présenter à partir
d'aujourd'hui une nouvelle émission
intitulée un acteur lien auteurs
aujourd'hui joseph bouillon lit proust
isabelle tourne à la tâche
il souffre est abominablement la mer
était démontée
c'était comme si on y ont pensé par m
[Musique]
voilà je suis avec le professeur dit var
à bord d'un engin très très très
spacieux femme est contente de mon jeu
de boules un professeur de quoi
s'agit-il
il s'agit de pet au numéro deux et
numéro deux une navette une navette une
navette qui marche comment un mec qui
marchent à gaz des espèces de râles
hausse découle évidemment à gaz butane à
gaz propane comme nous allons partir
dans l'espace professeur ses formes y
ont voient pas sur le coeur mais nous
sommes déjà dans l'espace processeur
mais je voulais sûr mais regardez mais
regardez enfin j'aperçois j'aperçois le
toit les bergénias laignel oui j'ai
pensé à cela
avant de décoller il faut que j'aille
chercher les provisions de bouche vous
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez me ramener
s'il vous plaît un sandwich au jambon
une canette de bière
merci professeur pektas j'étais persuadé
que dans l'espace
aujourd'hui
économique et social l'été 1985
aura-t-il été propice pour tous les
hôteliers qui vivent sur le littoral
excusez moi petit problème
ni que
à
ah ah
économique et social l'été 1985
or at il été bénéfique pour tous les les
hôteliers de du littoral provence alpes
côte d'azur
c'est une question qu'on est appelé à se
poser à se poser tiens
ah ah
dynastique d inique
dans le cas où pendriez en cours de
route cette grande saga historique
voici un résumé des épisodes précédents
l'histoire se déroule dans une
principauté imaginaire situé à 30
kilomètres de nice à crapaud quel joli
kraby bonjour les travaux quel joli
prince je vais lui faire un bisou
bonjour le prof la bienfaitrice en
m'embrassant tu a rompu le sort qu'on
avait jeté sur mon berceau qu'elle étend
leur beauté moi je fais partie la
dynastie des ebooks d'ebook quel est ton
prénom
nadine naji nouveau j'ai bien connu ta
mère
ça s'appelle un coup de foudre le prince
lui l'ue va immédiatement demandé la
main de la belle n'a dit ni mook à son
père le roi devra partir pour jérusalem
j'ai mokhtar tu devras me ramener 2 kg
de boudin blanc dès que le prince lui
par pour jérusalem ne dîne se fait
enlever par le pesq à tort et son fidèle
akbar je n'ai maclou ils l'entraînent
dans son harem aux confins du désert
[Musique]
là
k
oui
pendant ce temps lui arrive à jérusalem
et rencontres kasseem jr d'un blanc
[Musique]
achat l amène à sa manière
pendant ce temps le pesq à tort commence
à saturer de la belle n'a dit ni mook et
essaye de la revendre le temps chambre
il la gandoura et brûlé je n'ai play les
bas rouges de cette mon coeur je peux
plus qu'attendu l'ouvrier france et
blanc de préférence je peux plus je peux
plus je fais quelque chose tout de suite
à l'eau les bars à sion prévient passe
moins les petites annonces
le prince lui oublie nadine ebooks dans
les bras des chats écrasés
tu sais toi la phrase qui tirait bien
celle de bachelard si je trouve plus con
que moi je veux tu pourras c'est tout
c'est vrai parce que ma mère le disait
un plus long que toi hunger je peux pas
je peux pas vivre avec toi je peux plus
rester avec à ba1 alors je me casse je
retourne chez kassim avec lui au moins
je pouvais discuter avec lui au moins je
pouvais philosopher eh ben ça tombe bien
parce que je commençais moi aussi en
avoir marre claque
aïcha écrasé lorient serait ennaji bon
d'accord ça volait pas haut -
l'embrasser elle pensait à la décoration
de la maison celle là va chez ta mère
tiens elle n'aura pas eu le temps
d'aller chez sa mère à 25 ans même des
noms prédestinés elle tient à les chats
écrasés ce avec l'asie voilà c'est tout
d'où l'expression pour plus verts qui
avaient par la suite qu'elle fit un
pierre berger allemand est à son tour
mordu pour nadine mercier
quel joli berger allemand j'ai dû faire
un petit bonjour les bergers allemands
bonjour et belle enfant tu sais qu'on
évitait exactement les gars de ta maison
tu fais pas ta me ouamane le décor est
planté
les personnages aussi où vous êtes
maintenant fin prêt à suivre la suite de
cette grande saga la dynastie des ebooks
ne ratez pas dès samedi prochain
votre grand feuilleton qui dromadaires
la dynastie des boucs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
vous êtes tous là pour rigoler en
fronton failli beaucoup d'impôts mais
qu'est ce qu'on rigole
vous allez l'avoir la dernière alors
justement là voilà qu'arrive l'histoire
de deux chinois de chinois qui marchent
dans une rue
et alors nos deux chinois arrivent en
sens inverse
n'est ce pas et arrive à un moment où
ils vont se croiser et à ce moment
précis où ils se croisent d'ici un
regard de l'autre et lui dit salut
maurice salut maurice
salue marie
[Musique]
mathieu regarde à la mûre
tout ce monde
les étoiles eux
[Musique]
haha
je
[Musique]
m
là
les familles célèbrent la véritable
histoire d'amour
césar et bart en toi et hop un jeu plus
complet
j'ai appris que des revues césar
aujourd'hui je t'interdis de leurs voix
j'ai le droit d'accueillir ces armes ont
pas laissé le clairement dit je te le
redis de revoir ce genre toi mais jaloux
et la shoah
[Musique]
c'est ça
mon césar marc antoine
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir voici
l'émission humoristique d'affaires 3 et
wii avec une première histoire
l'histoire de deux chinois qui se rend
compte alors la seule émission qui
dérègle même votre téléviseur des
membres semaine la monnaie j'ai pas de
mode et de la beauté
depeche mode et parfois
[Musique]
voilà notre émission
nous allons nous quitter mais nous
allons nous retrouver la semaine
prochaine samedi prochain ne manquez pas
notre nouvelle émission tous les samedis
sur fr3 et je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée
[Musique]